Let's
continue on with our study of
rotation of functions around
the x, and we'll soon
see the y-axis as well.
So let's do a slightly harder
example than what we've been
doing, but I think it might be
obvious how to approach it.
So there's my y-axis, there's
my x-axis, and in a couple of--
I think it was two problems
ago-- we figured out if we had
the function y is equal to
square root of x-- let me try
to draw it-- so this is y
equals square root of x-- if we
were rotate that around the
x-axis, what the volume would
be between two points, let's
say 0 and some other point.
Now let's just pick an
arbitrary point 1.
I think you know how to
do that at this point.
Now let's make it a slightly
more difficult problem.
Let's say I were to also
draw the function y is
equal to x squared.
So that looks-- if this is 1,
they both meet at 1, right?
Because square root of 1 is 1,
and 1 squared is 1, so that
would look something like this.
They should be actually
symetric around y
equals x, but anyway.
So say y equals x squared
looks like that.
So my question now is, what
is the volume if I were to
take this figure and
rotate it around?
So what do I mean?
So this area here, if I were to
rotate that about the x-axis,
what would the volume be?
So now, what we did just with
the square root of x, we had
like a solid cup, right?
It would look
something like this.
It would be like a cup, and it
was solid, we were just trying
to figure out the volume of it.
Hopefully that made
sense to you.
Now it's going to be kind of a
hollowed-out cup, because we
have this inside function, and
so the inside of the cup
is going to be empty.
Hopefully that makes
a little sense.
Remember you're just taking
this and then you're rotating
it around the x-axis.
Well, the way to think about
it-- especially if you having
trouble visualizing--
actually, the solution might
help you visualize it.
The volume of this figure,
which I'm having trouble
drawing, it will be the
volume formed by the
outside rotation of this y
equals square root of x.
We'll do that in the yellow.
It'll be the volume formed when
that is rotated around, and
then the whole solid volume
minus the volume when
minus this volume.
So if we took the y equals x
squared, y equals x squared
would look something like that,
and then if you rotated it
around the axis, it would
look something like that.
I don't know if you've ever
been to Morocco, but they have
these tajin plates that the
tops look a lot like that.
Well, you probably haven't.
Well, anyway.
It would look
something like that.
So if we subtract out this
volume when it's rotated around
from the volume of y equals
square root of x, when that's
rotated, we'll get this figure
that we're trying to figure
out, this area when
it's rotated around.
And that should be intuitive
for you, hopefully, because
when we just did area under a
curve, that's how we would
figure out the area
of this green area.
We would figure out the area
under square root of x, and
we'd subtract out the area
under y equals x squared.
This time, we're going to say
the volume of the revolution of
y equals square root of x minus
the volume of the revolution
of y equals x squared.
So let's do the problem.
So the total volume-- let me do
a good color, that looks good--
total volume is going to be
equal to the volume formed when
we rotate y equals square
root of x around the x-axis.
I said from 0 to 1, and
that's because I picked
where they meet.
Sometimes in a book, or on an
exam, they'll just say, oh, you
know, the area between y equals
x squared and y equals square
of x, we're going to rotate
that around and you have
to figure out, well they
intersected at 1, and you can
just set the equations equal to
each other to figure that out.
We're going from 0 to
1, because they also
intersect at 0.
0 squared is the same thing
as square root of 0.
We're going from 0 to
1, and so what's the
volume of the larger?
Or I guess the y equals square
root of x rotated around?
I always forget the formula,
that's why I always redraw a
disk, so if that's the radius
of my disk, the disk is going
to come around like that, so
we know that the radius is a
function of the disk, and
that's, of course, the dx
is the depth of the disk.
So the radius is the function
which, for the outside one, is
square root of x, and we know
area of this disk is pi r
squared, so we square the
radius, take a pi outside, and
then we multiply that times the
width, so that's where we
get our dx, and of course we
sum them all up and that's
where we get the integral.
I'm going to do it as
two separate integrals.
Some people will put them both
within the same integral, but I
really want to hit the point
home that this is the volume of
the outside surface, formed by
the outside surface or the cup,
minus the volume formed by
the the inside function.
It's going to be minus pi--
still going to be from 0 to 1--
I drew fairly huge integral
signs, I don't know why-- and
what's the inside function?
It's x squared, and that's
going to be the radius of its
own disks, if that's the
radius that's the disk, dx
is the width, so it'll be x
squared, squared, times dx.
So let's see if we
can figure that out.
So, volume equals--
let's take the pis out.
I think you'll see that that
pi is applying to everything,
so we can take the pi out.
And then, times the integral,
and now we can merge them
back, because integrals
are additive like that.
You'll see what I'm
talking about.
This integral is
the same thing.
So what's square
root of x squared?
Well that's just x.
And what's x squared, squared?
That's x to the fourth, right?
You multiply the exponents,
exponent rules.
We have a minus sign here.
Minus x to the fourth, all that
times dx, we've got that pi on
the outside, that equals--
let's keep our pi
on the outside.
We're going to have to evaluate
the antiderivative at 1 and 0.
So what's the
antiderivative of x?
Well, that's x squared over
2, minus-- what's the
antiderivative of
x to the fourth?
Well, it's x to
the fifth over 5.
That's hopefully
second nature to you.
x to the fifth over 5, and
we're going to evaluate
that at 1 and 0.
1 and 0.
We're going to subtract them.
Fundamental theorem
of calculus.
So that equals-- I'm going to
switch colors to avoid
monotony-- that equals pi
times, let's evaluate it at 1,
so it's 1/2 minus 1/5 and when
you evaluate it at 0, it's 0
minus 0, so when you evaluate
0, you get nothing.
And so what's 1/2 minus 1/5?
That's pi times 2, get a common
denominator of 10, 5/2 is 1/2
minus 2/10 is 1/5, so this
equals, this would be 3,
so we get 3pi over 10.
That's the volume formed.
So it's almost easier to
figure out the volume of
this figure than to draw it.
Anyway, I think I'll leave you
there with this video, and in
the next video, we're
going to start rotating
around the y-axis.
See you soon.